[Music]
it's sunday mass in puente de valetas
one of madrid's poor southern districts
for the congregation it's a moment of
reflection and a moment to think about
the week coming
the coveted rate here is one in every
hundred people
and this is their last day of freedom
tomorrow vanettas will lock down
people won't be able to leave this area
of the city unless it's for essential
work
or emergency medical care
[Music]
you don't have to go to church to find
some peace and quiet in madrid at the
moment
the baggage carousels at the airport
have stopped turning as the flights have
stopped landing
and the city's central railway station
is just as quiet
it feels like march all over again
[Applause]
and that's the problem forget the high
rates of transmission
many are just simply not in the mood for
yet another strict
lockdown
[Music]
my
basta the signs say it means stop
enough they might be against it
but the central government the central
spanish government in madrid
and the madrid local government are
being left with little choice against
the biggest
madrid is the worst affected city in
europe's worst affected country
in terms of infection rates spain is
around six weeks ahead of the uk
if the british government is watching
what is happening here it won't like
what it is seeing
the coming days could be tough aleister
bunker sky news
madrid
you